hey this is John Maloney with Ramsey
Network all right we got to have like a
family discussion here and if
something's been driving me bananas and
I'm not a ranter but dude so I think
this whole stay at home for eight weeks
or nine weeks or ten weeks and the Cova
discussion and all of the resulting
drama has been really exposing four
people's identity and who you think you
are and something that's kind of bubbled
up over the last few weeks is starting
to drive me crazy as this their complete
in utter lack of hospitality lack of
basic humanity on every side of an issue
and it's not just kovat it's all of it
I'm just using this as an example who
you freaking be kind here's the thing my
identity was always wrapped up in being
the smartest guy in the room being the
edgy dude being the guy that would like
take the joke and go right over a little
bit and try to be extra funny but a
little bit offensive and look any what I
ended up doing I ended up melting people
I thought wasn't fun to be around
anymore
I was painful it hurt because I was
annoying oh yeah you think that well
have you ever thought of this and
whatever dudes just science it's this
and you think that's bad you should hear
Meister whatever and I don't think I
started out that way trying to be mean
right I don't I I don't think I started
out thinking I only the smartest guy in
the room I really thought I had some to
add to every conversation I thought that
people were wandering around all the
time waiting for what dallona had to say
about something spoiler alert they
weren't they didn't care they liked
having me around they liked me for me
but if you remember that movie Fight
Club when they said people stopped
listening I stopped being with each
other
and they just started waiting for their
turn to speak that was me just
interjecting interjecting interjecting
oh yeah yeah soon as somebody started
with it with their opinion I was
formulating mine completely missing what
they were about to say so what does it
have to do with the present situation I
have never in my life experienced
something in the scientific community
like I've seen with the kovat stuff I
with doctors from all over the country
we've talked on the phone we've emailed
I've talked to him in person
and I've had really brilliant medical
doctors look at the science talk to
their patients and look me in the eyes
or say to me on the phone dude we're all
gonna die this is scary I'm gonna wipe
out a big chunk of us and I can hear it
in their voice they're not playing
they're not being dramatic and then I've
talked to other doctors I've talked to
other physicians I've read the papers
I've seen science and they've said hey
this is way way overblown we don't just
we don't know what's happening something
else must be going on there's some great
conspiracy theories on the youtubes on
the internets but this is not that big
of a deal so I've never found good
hearted brilliant people landing so far
on either side of the discussion so what
does have to do with you and me what
does have to do with Fight Club
what does have to do with just being
kind as we're opening up the world again
different states are handing a list
differently different governors
different mayors different people
different business owners and the
reality is we don't know we don't know
this is uncomfortable it's ambiguous
it's uncertain I think I have a pretty
good idea but the one thing that I can
guarantee you is I don't know I don't
know and you don't know and so when we
get out of the car at the gas station
and somebody's wearing a mask we can
roll our eyes and go home our cost
although we read about or we get to
choose to think blessings for them I
hope they're well hope they're doing
good hope their family's safe
conversely if I get out of the car and
I'm not wearing a mask you can look at
me and say what an idiot
that guy's trying to kill and hurt
people or you can say blessings on him
and his family hope he's doing well and
here's my position on the whole mask
thing it's a matter of hospitality right
like I didn't bring whiskey into my
grandma's house because that wouldn't
have been cool I didn't swear around my
granddad because I respected
and that was not appropriate when you're
in his presence so I didn't as a matter
of hospitality there's a matter of
kindness I open the door for people I'm
trying to start being on time more it's
just a matter of basic humanity so the
latest news on wearing a mask is it's
not gonna protect me it's gonna protect
other people and so if somebody asks you
to wear a mask put a mask on and if you
see somebody without a mask tell them
hello tell them good morning let's stop
fighting being right looking for places
in the world where other people are
violating your space going out every
second of every day looking for who's
trying to do that stop stop
let's all agree on this one thing as the
world opens back up we don't know what's
gonna look like
I know 36 million people are gonna get
hired back on Monday right it's gonna be
a slow gradual challenge for all of us
let's all decide let your identity not
be and being the right person in the
room being the edgy person in the room
being the snarky sarcastic person in
their rooms always gonna had the last
word or the last Oh did you know don't
be to that person don't be that guy
don't be that girl let's all just decide
hey let's queer me people of hospitality
we're gonna be people of kindness we're
gonna assume the other person was doing
the best they can with the tools they've
got let's be in this together let's love
each other together and I promise
whatever is on the other side of this
we're gonna come out stronger more
unified and more connected there's dr.
John Bologna make sure you subscribe
down below let's keep this conversation
going I look forward to seeing you soon
follow me at John Delaney all over the
interwebs and don't forget to shoot me
your emails that ask John at Ramsey
solutions com take care of peace out
have a great week